in the last video we took a guess at
what the solution was for our
differential equation and we came up
with an exponential
as our guess
and as we did the analysis we developed
a characteristic
equation we ended up with a complex
answer for one of the adjustable
parameters the natural frequency
of our circuit
so here's the form of our proposed
solution now this is getting kind of
complicated but i promise you it's going
to we're going to simplify this pretty
soon
we have
two solutions for s s1 and s2 that we
plugged in as plus or minus j omega
naught
and we have more adjustable amplitude
parameters that we have to figure out
so now in this video we're going to
continue on solving our differential
equation this is our proposed solution
this is a pretty complicated looking
expression
and what we're going to call on here now
is something really important in
electronics and in general
and it's called euler's
identity
we're going to use this identity to
figure out what to do with these complex
exponential terms
so if you search on this term on khan
academy you'll find an explanation of
where these identities come from
but i'm just going to state them right
here
and what it says is that
euler's identity is e
to the
j
x anything up there
equals
cosine x
plus
j times
sine x
that's one of the identities and the
other identity is e to the minus
j x
equals
cosine of x
minus
j
sine x
so these are useful because we have this
this exponential function with the with
the complex
unit inside of it when we go over to
this side
it's this is a sort of a normal complex
number cosine x is some number between
plus and minus one sine x is some number
between plus and minus one and it's just
a normal complex number so this may help
us simplify our life here as we as we
move forward all right so that's a
really important identity that we get to
use to solve our lc circuit
now i'm going to go back and rewrite
these two exponentials using
euler's identity here
and this is going to get big but it'll
collapse down pretty soon okay let me
move over here
i equals k1
times e to the plus j omega t let's use
this one here so that would be
cosine
x is
omega naught t
plus
j
sine
x is omega naught t
and we use the first one
okay now the second term is plus
k2
times now we have the negative
up in the exponent so we use this one
cosine
omega naught t
minus
j
sine
omega naught t
now we have our solution spread all out
across the screen and let's see if we
can uh
tidy things up here so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to gather all the cosine
terms together this one
and this one and then i'll gather the
sine terms together
okay so i equals
cosine omega not t
and cosine is multiplied by
k1
and
plus k2
all right
now let's add to that
uh we're gonna we have j sine and j sine
so i'll write
sine
omega naught t over here
and
j times what
j times
k one
and this time we have this minus sign
that makes it minus k2
all right so now
current is
some number times cosine
plus j times some number times sine now
these are two arbitrary constants and
i'm going to just make up another one
i'm just going to call this one
a1
and we'll call this one
a two
and we'll call that
i'll use the j
k one minus k two
and this now i can rewrite this
as
i equals
a1
cos
omega naught t
plus
a2
sine
omega naught t
good
so from now on we're going to work with
these a's and if i ever want to know
what the original k's were i would just
come back to these equations here
once i figure out a i can figure out
both the k's
so let's keep pressing on
how do we figure out a1 and a2
to do that we're going to use the
initial conditions the ics
and if we think back we remember that
in our original schematic
we had some q here
so which means we had a plus or minus v
zero v naught
and we had we said the current through
here
was started at zero so that's our
initial conditions
v of time equals zero
equals v naught
and
current
of time equals zero
equals zero
let's use these two values to help us
figure out what a1 and a2 are
and we'll do that in the next video as
we continue the derivation of the
natural response